Were the Nazis left wig?
That's a good question.
It depends.
See the problem with any question that says is a,
B is a equivalent to be,
is that it depends on how you define a and B.
Right?
And I'm not trying to weasel out of the question.
I'm very,
very,
uh,
serious about that.
The Nazis regarded themselves as national socialists,
you know,
so they,
they,
they weren't free market capitalists,
let's say.
So they certainly weren't right wingers in the way that free market capitalists
are right wingers,
even though they're probably more centrist.
Um,
they differed from the international socialists,
which were the Marxists because they were much more concerned with national
identity and racial identity.
And to the degree that you regard nationalism and racial identity as primarily
right wing views,
then the Nazis would have been right wing.
So let's say that they,
maybe they pulled from the worst of both extremes,
something like that.
But I do think it's reasonable to note that they're extreme nationalism and
ethnocentrism and racial identity probably has more in common with the radical
right that it does with the radical left,
which tends to be utopian universal.
So,
um,
one of the things I thought would be an interesting research project would be to
take like a hundred Nazi policies and to turn them into a questionnaire and ask
people either how much they agree with them after I figured out whether they
were left or right wing to begin with,
or whether they thought the policies were representative of the left or the
right.
Because that could be studied empirically.
And I don't think anyone's done it,
but that would be a very interesting,
uh,
that would be a very interesting research project.